It's time for Drew's News.
Come shake your news hips in our good news hula.
And with me at the desk is a man
who had his first hula right here, Ross Mathews.
Yes, I did, hi everybody.
(audience cheers)
Hi, Drew.
Hi, Rossy.
We've got a bowl of pasta today.
I know.
By the way, tell everybody what you said
when you walked out.
I said, "Oh, good, more carbs".
Thank you.
(they laugh)
All right, well, first up,
if you're about to walk down that aisle-
Ooh, yep.
But you're agonizing over
crafting that perfect wedding speech?
We've got a solution.
Metro reports that you can now hire
a ghost writer for your wedding.
Mm.
You've already got
a florist and a caterer,
so why not a wordsmith?
The company is called Speechy
and they write personalized speeches for brides, grooms,
best mens, wacky aunts, you name it.
And they really do a deep dive to make these personal,
they interview you beforehand and craft something unique,
specific and cliche free.
For anyone who thinks this is unromantic,
the company says the grooms get in touch months in advance,
'cause they just wanna get it right.
Well, let me ask you outta the gate,
because you're about to get married.
How would you feel if you,
(audience applauds)
I know!
I know.
How would you feel if Wellington resourced with Speechy?
Mm-hm, 'kay, let's talk about it.
So I have mixed emotions about this topic.
One, I'm like, no.
And then I'm like, wait a second, you know,
you think about it as a skillset, you know
I'm good at certain things, you know?
But algebra, I'm not good at.
Mm.
Roofing, I'm not good at.
(Drew laughs)
So I would hire someone to roof my house for me.
So if you don't have the particular skillset
of writing your intentions and your thoughts down,
maybe this would work for you.
That being said, Wellington, my fiance,
don't you dare.
(audience laughs)
I would rather my partner
came out and mumbled their way through their feelings.
And "I'm not good at this, but this is what you mean to me"
and mess it up and have it kind of be silly,
than to have it be perfect and written by some yoo-hoo.
You know what I'm saying?
So don't try it.
But if you need it, I mean, I guess, good for you.
Okay, so you're halfsy-halfsy?.
I don't wanna be, but I kind of am.
I don't wanna judge anybody else, but duh-uh, uh-uh.
(audience laughs)
Okay Ross, your story.
All right, next up, we've got a style trend
you're gonna see everywhere this season.
InStyle reports this spring,
it's all about the high low look.
We're talking short in the front and long in the rear.
It's like a mullet skirt.
It's shirts with trains and skirts with trains.
It's the perfect look for anyone who suffers from
a chronically chilly booty,
or just wants to try a tail.
Look at this, it's basically like a butt flap.
It's a booty-be-gone.
So I think this trend is taking off
because as a culture, we're sort of obsessed with booties.
So this feels so demure.
Yeah.
Well think, it started with like a JLo and a Kim K.
We all wanted that big booty.
So if you didn't have it, you're sort of insecure.
Yeah, are you guys doing this though?
Are you wearing the long trend?
I actually have a couple of shirts.
I think it's kind of cute with a jean
Hands up, who thinks that this is fashionable and cool?
The trains.
Okay.
Who thinks it looks
like a hot mistake?
(scattered audience giggling)
You don't like it?
These cuts are, you know,
when something is kind of on the bias
and it's sort of tea length in the back,
a little shorter than the front,
but it's kind of an illusion and you're like, oh.
This just looks like,
it does look like mud flaps.
Yeah, oh the one on the semi, right?
Yeah, with the naked girl.
Yes, which I love those.
I love those.
I used to have earrings of her.
This is not what I will be wearing to your wedding, Ross.
Oh, okay.
Wait, can I go back?
You used to have earrings of the mud flap,
with the girl on it?
Hell yes.
You know what I like about you?
What?
You're so weird.
(audience laughs)
(Ross laughs)
It's funny 'cause it's true.
(bright theme music)